check out halle berry at the 2021 oscars
showing off a chic but much shorter new
do on the red carpet
the moment also marks her and boyfriend
van hunt's red carpet debut
hallie shared this pic of the pair to
instagram seemingly snapped before
arriving to union station hey kids
hallie's donned in a strapless blush
pink dolce gabbana gown
it features a plunging neckline and
oversized bow
at the waist the musician looked suave
in a dark velvet suit
moments before hitting the red carpet
together ally teased her shorter tresses
posting
this pic to twitter a reminder this is
how she was rocking her hair
recently this isn't the first time she's
gone short at the oscars though
this is her in 2017 and who can forget
this iconic look in 2002 when she won
her best actress statue last month van
opened up to et
about his romance with hallie but hallie
did post a picture of you saying that
you are her
muse is she your muse has she influenced
like what music you're
producing now well in more ways then
i could even tell you right now i i
could show you better than i could tell
you
and i will show you really soon i
promise
the inspiration uh for our relationship
goes across
everything even in my parenting so it's
it's you i'm a completely different
person i can say it like that
and i think that it's improved every
every aspect of my life
that's prob that's one of the biggest
compliments i'm sure she probably feels
like she could get and that you can give
somebody yeah and it's probably the only
time it'll be said
because i i'm sure you'll find out or
you probably
already know i'm a very private person
you know i don't talk about
personal things in my life or the people
in my life
so you know but i do there are things
that i want the world to know
you know and i've already shared that
much with you that that's going to be it
you